hello hello and good morning and welcome
welcome to sunny Redmond it's summer in
Seattle you can tell the rain is a
little bit warmer welcome to Microsoft
and more importantly welcome to the
Microsoft research faculty summit I am
delighted to be your host here for the
next couple of days in the MC for your
event I hope you I was delighted
actually to see many of you at the
Welcome Reception last night I hope you
had a chance to enjoy that as much as I
did meeting some new people renewing
some old acquaintances I hope that
that's the the start of a really
wonderful experience for us all over the
next two days I am sandy Blythe I run
the outreach for research at Microsoft
around the world outreach people our
programs and resources are intended to
create and maintain a really
collaborative rich environment where
Microsoft and academia can work together
on research areas of interest and
advance the state of the art and that's
really foundational to helping Microsoft
and Microsoft Research achieve the
vision for MSR which is to be an basic
open research facility in the best
academic traditions you know us we
publish openly we publish more than any
technology industrial technology lab in
the world we publish in peer reviewed
journals and at top conferences we make
our datasets available for transparency
and reproducibility I'd encourage you to
become familiar with MSRs open data
repository where we make many of those
MSR datasets available as well as the
recently announced as your open datasets
for more public datasets and in
publishing
we the majority of our papers are done
with an external academic collaborator
so it truly is the best academic
tradition that we hold ourselves to in
helping to advance the state of the art
I'm very excited to have here I'm
excited to have we've also got some
press that will be joining us over the
next couple of days so you're aware but
faculty summit has really been a year in
the planning and because of the
dependency and the engagement we have
with academia it's a special event for
us it's something that we look forward
to throughout the course of the year
it's a special event because we get to
renew old acquaintances and get to meet
some new people
we have a group of attendees about two
hundred and fifty external academics and
researchers from around the world
we've got attendees from 20 countries
around the world about a hundred and
twenty-five institutions so a really
rich diversity of thought and experience
that I think makes this a really unique
event it's also a special anniversary
for us with the faculty summit this is
our 20th faculty summit that we've done
here in Redmond and so it's an
opportunity not only for us to look
forward topically with the future of
work but also to look back over the past
20 years that we have done work together
you've seen we have some special guests
later on tonight as our closing talk
will have an opportunity to have a
conversation with Bill Gates who as the
founder of Microsoft and really the
chief sponsor of MSR who made a
remarkable commitment to long-term
research when you know as a little
company with challenging purpose and
it's remarkable that we have been able
to sustain that investment at Microsoft
and with each of you and I'm excited for
us to all have a chance to hear from
Bill is not only he looks back but looks
forward on some of the topics of
interest for us all the the summertime
here is the time it's super busy for all
of you and I recognize that you've got a
lot of demands a lot of options that you
can spend your time with and so we're
really grateful that you've chosen to
spend your time with us over the next
two days here at faculty summit please
do let any of the Microsoft team know if
there's anything that we can do to make
this the best experience that we can for
you the agenda is crafted with your
feedback in mind from the topic the the
future of work to the way we lay out the
agenda so we have keynote speakers from
both Microsoft and from outside
institutions to give kind of broad
overviews we've got some breakout
sessions that allow us to go deep on
more specific topics we've got plenty of
time for networking one of the best
feedback that we get from attendees is
that they really appreciate the chance
to network with peers who have an
interest in common research topics to
expand their networks and to to gain the
access to some really interesting
feedback and challenging ideas we've
limited the attendance so we can make it
a little bit more of an intimate event
so in addition to about 250 external
attendees we'll have probably about 100
to 150 microsoft people who will be here
over the course of the next two days
those are Microsoft researchers research
leaders and research and Technology
leaders from our product groups as well
and I hope you have the opportunity to
engage with them to hear about what
we're doing and and also to give them
the opportunity to hear about what you
are doing it's a super exciting time for
us to focus on this topic the future of
work there is so much going on and not
just in technology there are all the
attendant changes as a result of
productivity technology advances on
policy regulation ethics and education
it's truly a momentous time and one of
the reasons that we were so excited to
pick the topic of the future of work for
this year's faculty summit so let's get
to work here's a quick snapshot of the
agenda well we've got a keynote this
morning that I'm super excited we have
Jamie T van from Microsoft and Gloria
mark from the UC Irvine who will be here
to get us started you can see how the
agenda flows will be going into breakout
sessions immediately across the hallway
for topics as we go along through the
day you'll be able to find your way back
to lunch where we had breakfast this
morning also tomorrow you'll see a cross
or approximate to where we were having
breakfast is a technology showcase which
will have 27 different booths
highlighting some of the
research and researchers at MSR that we
have ongoing I'll talk more about that a
little bit later but lots of breakout
sessions that give you the freedom and
the flexibility to choose some topics
that you would find interesting and to
engage in a more intimate way we also
try and turn this into a fun and
enjoyable social and networking event so
you can see after we have our
conversation with Bill later today we've
got an opportunity to head down downtown
Seattle for dinner at the to hooli
gardens and glass and a special surprise
experience that I'll describe in just a
moment you may have seen on the agenda
for lunch today we have a something that
we call one table one topic and you
might be wondering what that is well we
have senior researchers and Technology
execs from our product groups who've
been signed up to facilitate a
conversation around topics of interest
this is a completely optional thing but
if you see a topic or an individual
there that you'd like to get to know
better or you just want to talk amongst
peers over lunch on a something of in
common interest go ahead and look for
the table tent the little notice on the
tables and have a seat and join your
peers for a conversation of focused
around those things again it's optional
if you'd like just have a seat and enjoy
a nice lunch with your peers before we
come back for the breakout sessions the
one table one topic that has
historically been a really popular
element to our agenda and I encourage
you to consider that as you like you'll
also see throughout the day here in the
main tent you saw it hopefully at
breakfast you'll see them on the
monitors in the hallway what we call a
researcher spotlight and this again is
just another way as we have a very
diverse audience of attendees for you to
get to know both the research interests
and a little bit about the people who
are in attendance here this is a fun way
for us to introduce ourselves to each
other
I if you haven't seen Gloria marks
researcher spotlight I won't steal the
surprise but I will say that my esteem
for this woman knows no bounds and
you'll see her researcher spotlight fun
fact in a little while
as I say at dinner tonight if you have
never been to the Chihuly Gardens it's a
really special experience even those of
us from Seattle who have the opportunity
to to go to the artists location and see
the remarkable work that Dale Chihuly
and his students have produced it's a
really fun experience in addition to
being a delightful location for dinner
so I'm excited for us to hop on the
buses at the end of today and go down
for a special experience of vegan if
you've not been there before it's super
and if you have you'll know how good it
is and I hope you enjoy an opportunity
to revisit the Chihuly garden as a
special experience we're delighted to
let you know that after dinner we'll
have some opportunities to head up to
the refurbished Seattle Space Needle and
have an opportunity for a private
viewing of what I hope is some clearer
skies in the Seattle skyline it's a just
a breathtaking 360 degree view of the
Emerald City and there's a newly
installed glass floor if you've got the
nerve I don't to look down I understand
it's a very exciting view from up there
but we'll have three shifts after dinner
one at nine one at 9:30 and one at ten
o'clock if you'd love to go do that it's
a really fun experience don't look down
that will have the last bus will be
leave us is leaving right at the end of
dinner but the last bus I'll say leaves
at 10:45 if you missed the last bus at
10:45 welcome to Seattle yeah we do have
uber I do want to take a moment just to
refresh and introduce perhaps some of
our existing fellowships and grants
programs that MSR runs as well as
introduce some new programs that you
might not be familiar with I'll start
with our research Fellows program in our
that is managed out of our India lab in
Bangalore we have a number of academics
who've made the long flight from India
thank you very much I'm grateful to have
you here looking forward to being back
for the academic summit that we co-host
with ACM India at the end of January
this year so thank you for making the
trip the Fellows program gives
pre-doctoral students the opportunity to
come in and spend one to two years in
labs it's a cash stipend but they also
have the opportunity to work in the
Bangalore lab next to Microsoft
researchers and gain some real-world
experience that they can take into the
early part of their PhD program in their
research careers it has a long tradition
of producing some really outstanding
research as that lab does in systems in
theories in low resource environments as
well as supporting a new center that
outreach and MSR India have launched
around social impact of cloud and AI
technologies that were very excited to
have people contribute to there is a new
fellowship that we just recently
announced here in North America called
the Ada Lovelace fellowship in honor of
Countess of Lovelace really the world's
first computer program or a woman who
recognized the potential of the Babbage
machine it is intended to help foster
the development of a more diverse
community of students that are pursuing
their PhDs in North America and it
recognizes that there are some special
systemic or systemic obstacles so it's
an extension of our traditional PhD
scholarship program and it is a three
year program a full tuition $42,000
annual stipend you can see the inaugural
class that we awarded here in 2019 as
well as the dates for call for
nominations for the next Ada Lovelace
scholarship round if you go to Microsoft
comm WAC research and look for the
drop-down box programs and events
but we're very excited to have really an
upgraded a upgrading fellowship program
aimed at underrepresented groups in
computer science as I mentioned we do
have and will continue with our
traditional research PhD fellowship this
is a two-year program here in North
America many of you have students I'm
sure that our have been recipients or
are currently recipients of that and
again the the next date for the call for
nominations for the PhD Fellowship is on
the website
our MSR aja lab
headquartered in Beijing with an
expanded lab that will be opening at the
end of summer in Shanghai so were very
excited about and thank you for I think
about 50 attendee or excuse me about 35
attendees from the Asia region have
joined us here today in the faculty
summit thank you for making the long
trip this is both a cash and an
experiential opportunity where they not
only get a stipend but they have again
the opportunity for an optional
internship attendance at things like the
Asia faculty summit and academic
environment as well as some mentorship
and some travel stipends so again a very
rich holistic approach to enabling
technology leadership and entrepreneurs
in out of our Asia region we have a
dissertation grant this is meant to get
that on a final push across the line for
people especially in underrepresented
groups to get their terminal degree so
it's you know frequently it's that last
mile it's so hard to get your
dissertation completed and presented and
win your degree and so this is a cash
stipend that helps get that individual
across the line and into either an
academic or industrial research career
we have in addition to some new
scholarships we brought back some old
fellowships that were very popular and
really in looking back at the history of
the faculty fellowship we saw some
remarkable talent that has gone on to do
some fantastic research work and it was
very inspiring for us to see what our
support early in career had been able to
do and we're delighted to have brought
that back again this year so the
research Microsoft research faculty
fellowship is a two-year $100,000 per
year grant to those early in career much
like an NSF Career Award to help them
get started on what we believe will be a
really promising and impactful research
career and I'm delighted if you haven't
seen these were this was the first class
of the renewed faculty fellowship that
we made awards to earlier this year if
you know them you see them congratulate
them we are thrilled to be associated
with young researchers of this caliber
there's also a new fellowship from our
education team in Microsoft we call it
the investigator fellowship it is also
two years $100,000 each year and it's
intended to support researchers and
educators who are using Azure in
interesting ways for their research and
educational purposes again that's new
it's not a Microsoft research fellowship
it's from our education group and we're
delighted to be doing the first call for
that investigator fellowship here
shortly and then finally as we do in all
of the other regions that we operate
around the world we have our scholarship
program in amia for Europe Middle East
and Africa this is centered on a
research lab in Cambridge UK the first
lab that we opened outside of the United
States it too is a to excuse me a
three-year scholarship at travel and
living stipend and includes the
opportunity to have a mentor and
collaborations with the research team in
our cambridge UK lab so really a very
exciting lineup of fellowships and
grants that i hope you'll take the time
to get familiar with and encourage your
students or other young faculty that
you're familiar with to take a look at
and evaluate it has a tremendous history
we hope that it is just part of the
environment that we can create that
creates a really rich and collaborative
partnership between MSR and academia
there's clearly a lot else going on with
MSR the questions I frequently get about
hey how do I keep up with all that's
going on hopefully online is a great way
for us to keep up I've already mentioned
the website Microsoft comm lack research
where you can see everything that we've
going on across the programs in MSR labs
around the world we have a podcast
series which is proven to be very
popular kind of get helps you to get to
know the individuals behind the research
as well as the path that has brought
them to MSR in their areas of
investigation we're starting to do those
actually now jointly between Microsoft
researchers and their academic partners
or their advisors
which is a lot of fun to sort of extend
the journey and include our academic
collaborators in the podcast series but
Facebook Instagram Twitter there's lots
of ways to stay in contact with us
there's an MS our newsletter that I hope
you'll take the opportunity to subscribe
to as well as the MS our blog in our AI
blog so hopefully lots of ways to keep
up to date on the lots of things that we
have going on together as we produce a
really state-of-the-art research and
pursue research of common interests
[Applause]